[Music]
don't forget to enter our amazon gift
card giveaway all you have to do is be a
subscriber like and comment
hey guys in this video we're going to
talk about danny's fate in the final
episode of game of thrones
supportive village leagues yes dany is
going to die in tonight's episode
jon snowbill killer that's the
bittersweet ending we'll get
although i'm not quite sure what's sweet
about this ending then it does john is
destroyed
the rest of our favorite characters are
already dead except for tyrion who
becomes the hand of the king for the new
king of the seven kingdoms
that is chosen democratically bran stark
sounds like a fan fiction
and very poorly written one but
unfortunately the leak is legit
sounds horrible let's hope there are a
few surprises that leak forgot to
mention
alright so at the end danny gets killed
by jon snow that's her final prophesied
betrayal
betrayal for love before that there must
be more of dany in the final episode
right well not exactly she will not even
live until the end of an episode
but rather dies in the beginning or
somewhere in the middle of an episode
the first mention of dany in episode 6
is when john davos centerian walked to
the ruins of king's landing
overseeing the outcome of all the fire
and blood dany unleashed in last episode
then they come across dennis armies
commanded by grey worm who trapped the
remaining lannister soldiers
and are about to kill them then he
commanded her armies to kill every
remaining enemy soldier
which upsets jon and tyrion jump leads
greyworm to stop this madness
but greyworm tells them it's the queen's
orders and kills them
then john sees danny and dragon behind
her and as she walks down the stairs
drogon's shadow makes denny look like
she has giant things
weird scene i know the first scene danny
talks is when she walks out of the red
keep
and gives a speech to her armies she
says to the cheering the tracky and
disciplined unsullied
that they just freed the people from
king's landing and the new goal is
freeing the rest of the world
yes danny to our big disappointment has
become the mad queen
don't get me wrong it's not dany
becoming this mad tyrant what upsets me
it's how we have got there and how she's
become one the issue is not necessarily
with what we got
it's how we got there a rushed
inconsistent mess of a season
with dark slaying dialogue tormund's
statement what kind of a person rides a
dragon
a madman or king did strike me as some
kind of a foreshadow for what's to come
danny being the mad one and jon being
the true king
that's not enough then he did say two
times in earlier season how she's going
to take back what's hers with firing
blood
and i'd be okay with that if dany in
season seven when she arrived they
instantly attacked king's laning
did what she did in last episode and
fulfilled her words
but she didn't and she promised to the
lancer soldiers that that's not her
but cersei who destroys the birth cities
and kills the innocent
she said she's come to save them then in
season 8 episode 3 she indeed saves
westeros with her armies and dragons
only to two episodes later used the same
army's center dragon to destroy the
capital of westeros
killing hundreds of thousands civilians
the showrunner said that the biggest
foreshadow for dany being this man
targaryen all along was dany watching
her brother viserys dive without a blink
and without any emotion i don't even
know what to say to this nonsense
should we have thought danny had this
dark side inside her because she did not
cry for her brother
the same brother who abused her sold her
to kyle drogo against her will
and when she tried to refuse the same
brother told her i'd let his whole 40
strong tribe take turns on you and his
horses too
if that means some getting their support
and on top of that threatened to kill
her
and her unborn child then his lack of
emotion for viserys foreshadowing her
becoming this mad queen is a ridiculous
statement by the showrunners to say at
the very least
then again they also said in season 8
episode 4 inside the episode video when
explaining that episode that dany kind
of forgot about euron's fleet that's why
she lost
rhaegal in season 8 episode 1 inside the
episode video when explaining that
episode they said that while sam's
father was a bad person
his older brother was a good lad older
brother
really really showrunners sam's entire
story is based on him being his father's
disappointment
and even though he was the heir to horn
hill as he was his oldest son
randall sent sam to the wolves so his
younger son sam's younger brother could
inherit the lordship instead of sam why
am i even surprised at this point
anyways the point is majority of us
don't have a huge problem with dany
being made the mad queen
we have a problem with how they wrote
her character and how they rushed her so
much to this point without a real build
up
here we are talking about the same
character who locked her two dragons
because they killed one single child
only to then use drogon to kill
thousands game of thrones may dany evil
in just one episode
back to dany's fate in episode 6. so
after she gives this speech about
freeing the rest of the world just like
how she freed people from king's landing
then he will then turn to tirion and
tell him he committed treason
tyrion tells her that she killed
thousands of innocent people and he
takes off the hand of the queen pin and
throws it
then he sends him to prison for freeing
his brother
then he did warn tyrion in the beginning
of episode 5 that if he ever fails her
again
it would be his last this is when tyrion
starts to conspire against dany
tyrion tries to convince jean to turn on
dany he tells him that his family will
never be safe
because it threatens dany's legitimacy
then he did reveal to tyrion early on in
episode 5 her feelings towards jon's
family
she sees sans as a traitor conspiring to
overthrow her in her mind sansa is the
reason where is betrayed her
and she is the reason her claim is
threatened tyrion will use this to
convince jean to kill dany if he wants
his family to live
john is convinced that his family will
never be safe because he represents a
threat to her rule
the next scene john goes to see her and
she's sitting on the arm throne alone
with no guards
and jon tells her that she needs to stop
this madness then he tells jon that
she's doing it for the people
jumper tends to understand when her
guard is down he stabs her and that's
how dany's story ends
just like that in the beginning or in
the middle of an episode dany dies
however i don't think jon only kills
dany here as i believe dan is pregnant
with his child
this makes jon killing dan even more
bitter as it's not only danny his
killing
but also their unborn child the season 7
heavily foreshadowed dany's pregnancy as
well as jon's future child
additionally many fans claim that in
these shots from last episode
then it does look like she is in her
early stages of pregnancy
however jon doesn't know this and john
killing dany is completely justified
this would only make it more bitter dany
has become the mad queen
and after what she did in episode 5 john
was left with no choice
it's funny that when you think about it
all the villains we had throughout the
story from joffrey to cersei ramsey and
the night king
all of them together did not kill as
many innocent people as dany did in just
one episode
king's landings got a population of 1
million people if not the vast majority
of this number then at least they have
danny just burned alive
then he did not have any reason
whatsoever to burn down the capital
the bells rang enemy army surrendered
and all she had to do was march her
armies on the red cape
kill cersei and take the city without
any killing simple as that
however dany decided to unleash firing
blood and kill all the innocent people
her armies followed her lead and started
slaughtering all the women and children
except for jon who tried to prevent
unnecessary killing
additionally even though jon knows dany
obviously went man then knows her
feelings towards his family jon still
gives danny one last chance
trying to talk to her to see if she
realizes what she's done is a huge
mistake and crime
that's jon snow and that's who he is in
last episode when he saw his own man
trying to force himself on a girl john
went to kill him
but even then jon gave him one last
chance before killing him
instead the soldier tried to kill him
and that's when jon ended his life
anyways danny tries to justify her
actions and that's when jamil realized
there's no turning back
she is this mad queen and a huge threat
to westeros having already destroyed one
great city
and hundreds of thousands of innocent
people and john will then kill her
i believe that's what dany's vision from
the undying was foreshadowing all along
then he wins the armed throne and
becomes queen of ashes that are covering
it
but she will not be able to ever sit on
it or at least not for long
because jon will have to put an end to
her madness where upon she'll join drogo
and her son on the other world
dany is after all the madqueen and i
guess the final villain of the story
perhaps that's why jon was resurrected
to stop dating the mad queen and to kill
the final threat
if this sounds disappointing to you wait
to hear what comes next
after dane is skill jogging comes into
the throne room and is standing over her
body
and he burns or melts the arm throne and
carries her away
i guess jon's plot armor is too strong
for jurgen to burn him
jon just killed his mother but jogon
instead burns the arm throne and leaves
alright jon probably kind of forgot dany
was his mother
after killing dany jon will then be
taken as a prisoner by dany's only
remaining loyalist grey warm
for some reason then his armies don't
kill jon or seek revenge over their
murdered queen by killing
pillaging and destroying rest of
westeros but just have john put on a
fair trial
once again logic in this one is strong
greywarm has tyrion and jon as his
prisoners
the council led by sansa tells grey worm
to release jon back to them
but he refuses tyrion is in front of the
council
and as a prisoner of grey worm he is not
making decision he is content with being
a prisoner
he makes suggestions only that centerian
says that the new king or queen should
decide what happens to jon
sam suggests a democratic vote for the
new king tyrion calls that idea stupid
the council votes and decides bryce
should be the king bran picks tyrion as
his hand
oh god i don't even know where to start
with this one as i said in my john snow
video a couple of days ago i find it
quite ridiculous that bran would be
chosen as a new king
it says that tyrion gives a speech
before brain is voted for a new king
so i guess it's tyrion's speech that
makes everyone vote for brain
but still if there was any sense left in
the show the character
sure scale would not vote for bran stark
over their rightful king john
on the one hand they have an experienced
leader commander and chewer to the armed
throne
that is kev stark have targaryen and
pretty much supported and loved by
everyone
and then on the other hand you have this
weird kid who knows and sees everything
yet is as useless as he can get jon
might have killed dany
but that doesn't matter he's their
rightful king for all they know dany
observed the throne
and jon had to kill her to take what's
his by his right
they would all vote for jon snow to be
their king once again i'm not saying the
leak is fake because it definitely is
not
it's legit but the ending is so
ridiculous and disappointing to me that
i cannot get over it
all the high lords are going to arrive
in king's landing during episode 6 from
robbing irene to the new prince of dorne
most will come to support jon's claim
varys informed everyone of big imports
that jon is a true heir
they are coming to support him only to
then vote for bran instead of jon to be
the new king
anyways bram picks tyrion as his hand
tyrion tells jon that his punishment is
going back to the wall
and joined the night's watch once again
no logic in writing whatsoever
why is there even need for the night's
watch when the world is broken and the
night king defeated
tyrion's dead graveyard wanted him dead
and sends someone a name back home
so nobody is getting what they want it's
a fair compromise
grey worm accepts jon's punishment he
doesn't bend the knee
leaves with his troops and the trachea
and ships to free slave cities
so basically instead of killing jon on
sight and raging revenge all over
westeros
dany's armies demand fair trial before
packing up and leaving
i get it they're going back to essos to
do what they imagined to do with them
before she was killed
but would not they at least seek some
kind of revenge before doing so
anyways this is exactly how denny's fate
and end will look like
some would think dany was destined to
become the queen of the seven kingdoms
she was the one who spent most of the
serious learning to rule
some thought it was jon snow
dishonorable and just northmen
true heir to the armed round and then it
ended up being bran
the kid who refused lordship of
winterfell because he is the
three-year-old raven now
but then he accepts to be the king of
the seven kingdoms
to make the stark swing and brain end up
on the throne the showrunners made dany
mad in just one episode so john could
kill her
this way then is obviously dead and
cannot be the queen while jon takes the
black for killing her
which makes him no longer a legitimate
heir to the throne
the season 8 was a huge disappointment
and if you thought the finale would
redeem it you were wrong the finale is
the biggest disappointment of it all
i don't like it one bit but hopefully
you guys do and hopefully you're not as
disappointed as much as i am
and as always i hope you guys enjoyed
this video if you did please make sure
to subscribe to our channel and i hope
to see you in the next one
peace